what's what's like your craziest
experience with a fan
craziest experience uh i'd probably say
the time a fan came up to me and she
asked me to
uh write love is love and i for some
reason i
misspelt love but she was gonna get a
tattoo on her wrist
and i was like i'm so sorry and she's
like no no no i'm gonna keep it
so i haven't seen it today but i'm sure
if you see someone that has love is love
with uh the love crossed out that's
probably uh
that's my artwork oh my god wait so wait
you ended up crossing out the love now
it got cool
so love is a dark it's a dark tattoo
mind you but i think it's cool
thank you yeah i crossed it out and
rewrote it and she was like i'm gonna
keep it and i was like okay
cool awesome i get so nervous when
people do that they ask me to do lyrics
and there and i don't know why i'm doing
it and they're like i'm gonna get it
tattooed and i'm like
i can't express you how bad of an idea
that is actually
like you shouldn't do that i was like
you might hate me one day i'm just
saying
like you could be like she sucks and
it's there
anyway it's so much pressure because i'm
like all right now it's
do i do cursive do i do box letters what
do i do
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure